yeah let's do it
oh yeah oh yeah
welcome to breakfast
with me
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to episode
100 of griffin with griffin
i want to always thank dopapod and
detective design
and all the guys that helped make this
great great music uh it's been a long
ride
a long robe we finally made it to 100
episodes
and i thank everybody for watching
and you know i don't even know what to
say so it's just gonna be really a
regular episode with a couple of
surprises but i really thank y'all for
watching
double line double line
and so we have a short segment of real
world advice from a grown ass man
um let's get it going so first one
is i told a girl i love her she said she
loves me
talking constantly but she has a
boyfriend well
i mean i mean love is what it is
you know but this isn't right
because you are setting yourself up for
failure
you know you starting on a bad foot i
mean listen if
the relationship that this girl is in is
not
obviously not healthy there obviously
something's going on that she's
dipping out in a way that she's telling
someone else that she
loves them so you already know
that this is a tricky situation now
listen i'm not saying that you have to
give up this relationship but you have
to be like but obviously you have some
chemistry just something there but
it might not be exactly what you think
it is if everything was
set up perfectly because it's almost
like an escape hatch it's almost like a
parachute to get out
because no matter what happens well
there's always this other drama on the
side there's always this thing over your
head
over the relationship so and and what is
it
in you that you want to be a part of
something like that
do you want an escape do you want to
make sure that you know
you don't let yourself down and let that
relationship down because now you know
well this isn't right in the back of
your head you're thinking to yourself
well
this is this is somehow going to fail
because this person has a boyfriend
so you know i don't know i think that
you should just be honest with
yourselves and be like hey
it's time to you know it's time to like
back away and be like hey i think you
should settle what's going on there so
we can move forward
or you have to understand exactly what
it is you know it's
it's like just because you say the word
love it doesn't cancel out everything
that's going on in
that situation i mean that's the myth i
mean the myth is love conquers all
but there's love obviously on the other
side too that's why they got together
and that's why they're together in the
first place so
this is not about love it's it's about
being practical it's about being like
you know just having common sense in
this situation i think you're asking
this question because you're like
just don't feel right something's up
here what do i do about this
well you either fight for this love
fight for this relationship by
going about it the right way look you
already messed up y'all already did
you're cheating right you're already the
other man right so
either be like okay look you need to
settle that
get out of that so we can start fresh or
you're gonna be just a side [ __ ] you
know what i mean that's what
that's what you are right now and so
if you're okay with that i mean it's not
right i mean it's you know it's it's
what are you supposed to say about it
like we all know i mean i think we've
all been in this situation where
you know you're in some kind of weird
relationship or you've or you let
yourself
say and do things that you regret or not
or you didn't you wish you had done
differently but
i mean it it is what it is you know it
really is what it is so you just have to
decide for yourself
like how far do you want to go
in these circumstances and
because it's gone it's not going to end
well
there will be a real dark time but you
also will be able to
come out of that if what you claim to
have is real
you know but you might also realize if
if there's nothing holding you back
if there's no other boyfriend if there's
you know the
situation is you if you guys are free
and clear you might not want that
neither one of you might not want that
so that's probably why
you're in this situation that you're in
but at least put yourself in that
situation to be like
hey is this what we want to do look i'm
not one of these people that's going to
be like
you know that's going to be it's wrong
so you should
no because you already did it the
action's already been done you've
already been talking you already got to
an intimate level that
was probably too far so now you have to
deal with the
situation deal with the circumstances
there's a situation but moving forward
if you wanted to
really if you wanted to work if you want
to feel better about your situation
you know it needs to be done and you
should do it so good luck
feel lost and confused about life
career-wise
mostly i don't feel passionate about
anything
yeah how do we find passion in things
that
things in our life things that we want
to do i mean it really is about taking
care of ourselves emotionally
spiritually and physically
i mean it sounds easy it sounds easy how
i'm saying or it sounds like oh that
seems simple but
i mean for real i mean when we're taking
care of our body
we're taking care of that that leads to
taking care of our mind
you know so it's like meditation it's
like
doing the things that you are passionate
about
that you don't even realize you're
passionate about them even if it's small
things
just being more tidy you know maybe
cleaning up maybe making your bed in the
morning you have to find
purpose in little things to build up to
bigger things
i mean when we say we're not passionate
about our life like
what are you trying to do you know
that's the thing we don't even sit down
and really sit down and ask ourselves
what do i want to do what do i want to
accomplish do i want to go to school do
i want to work
why am i not happy and you know the
answers are there
you know we oftentimes pursue jobs
and we stay at jobs that we don't really
like
but don't make us happy we're in
relationships we feel
stuck in relationships that we don't
really want to be in anymore but we feel
like
there's no other hope for anything else
or maybe like our career path went down
a way
that we just kept it going and didn't
realize that we didn't take any shots or
chances
so you just got to step back and ask
yourself like what do i really want to
do with my life
and once you find that little kernel of
like oh you know what that sounds
interesting
plant that sucker water it fertilize it
it takes time to
cultivate what you want to do and be
it's not going to happen overnight if
you're looking for a quick fix you're
not gonna find it especially not from me
right but i think that i think that
we're living in weird times so you have
to understand that like
because of the covet and the uncertainty
of our future
yes i think there are some emotions and
feelings that we all are feeling right
now that make us feel like
oh man what's going on in the world
what's going on with my life i don't
feel like i'm doing enough because we're
all not doing
enough or or we're not doing what we
used to do like
in my profession it's like i can't go to
comedy club so i gotta go to do
these weird shows outdoors and parking
lots and the beach and drive-ins so
that doesn't feel like is this what i
worked my whole career for
so that makes me feel unfulfilled but i
have to sit back and remember that
what's going on in the world affects
what's going on in
my you know my world so
i would suggest that you take a breather
understand that whatever feelings you're
feeling it's really
okay to feel them and then start to
really look at these little aspects of
your life
how are your relationships what kind of
relationships you're getting into and
just
your own self-care self-care is
important are you eating right are you
working out
like really take care of your body your
temple and it will start to lead to
uh better situations
in your life that's what i think so good
luck
here's one i think we all deal with
especially during these
political times but struggling trying to
educate some friends
on their ignorance towards racism
homophobia where's the line well that's
a good question where is the line
i mean a lot of times you know you can
have friendships with people who are say
you're a democrat they're a republican i
mean you know you just get to a point
where you go well we're just not going
to talk about politics
or even if like religion i mean there
are people like someone's catholic
another person is jewish another person
might be muslim
you know does it work smoother
that's more smoothly if everybody has
the same thought
thoughts and everybody has the same
religions and politics
probably maybe or that's just or you
just checked it off the list of the
things you don't have to worry about
and other things might come up but looks
and we're all different creatures
but that being said if you feel that
your friends
are are have a belief system that is
just completely opposite of yours and
they're not getting it when you try to
talk about it calmly
or if you just try to have a a real
intellectual back and forth with people
and they still feel the same way in in
in terms of the views of
racism and you know homophobia
well then you got to reconsider like are
these people are these the kind of
people i want to hang out with
or you just have to recognize oh these
are my friends that don't like gay
people
and are real ignorant about this or that
or
they have racist views and you just you
just know well i'm getting other things
from them and i have to just
you know step back i mean what how do
you what do you want to do you know
you can't change people's minds all you
can do is all you can do is
worry about how you feel about things
you just have to lead by example
you know but if it's really starting to
bother you
for all of us if you're hanging out with
somebody who just like if you're hanging
out with somebody even if it has
something to do with these kind of
subjects you could be hanging out with
somebody that drinks too much
they may not necessarily have a drinking
problem but they're the kind of people
that like to party all the time
right they want to go to the club every
other night they like to get they like
to get
turned up you know and you it's just not
your thing
you gotta go ah you know i'm not gonna
go out with you guys
but if that's the thing that they wanna
do all the time and they wanna do it
with you and you can't then you have to
find
other ways to be friends with this
person or you just go well you know we
tried and
i need to find people who have my
similar interests so i know you
obviously care about these people and
you don't want
but then you don't also don't want to be
like the you know the guy preaching at
everybody all the time i've been in that
situation where i've been that guy you
know i remember when i was in high
school
all my friends were drinking and smoking
and doing stuff and i was the one being
like you shouldn't do that you shouldn't
do that
you know what ends up happening people
start to go i don't want to hang out
with that guy
they just go all right uh we're gonna go
do this and they just that's what that's
what happens
so make which might be the best thing
for you
so i know that's a hard situation you've
tried and make sure you try it with love
and compassion and when it doesn't work
you got to make that choice like sorry
but i got to
move on good luck
all right here's our video question of
the week
hey what's up griff big fan so uh my
question is
after a bunch of bad relationships i
feel like i've lost my mojo
uh what advice could you give me
okay so this one is
um wait let's get it let me make sure
i'm getting it right
make sure i'm getting right so he's a
big fan which i do appreciate
but after some bad relationship he feels
like he's lost his mojo any advice
well you know it feels like i'm it feels
like i'm giving the same advice to
everybody every week about this type of
thing
it's like you don't lose your mojo you
just start
you're just doubting yourself you're
starting to feel like you're not doing
the things that you did before so you
got to think back what were you doing
before but the way you get your mojo
back the way you feel
confident and about yourself is to like
start taking care of yourself
do things that make you feel good about
yourself whether that be succeeding at
your job whether that be like
cleaning up your house whether that be
you know starting to work out whether it
be meditation whether it be like
those things that you do that give you
that feeling of like yeah i'm the man or
yeah i did it so you got to start doing
though
more of those things i mean just because
you had bad relationships i mean it is
what it is
because even if you look at those
relationships and you start to really
intellectualize like what happened in
the relationship that
um made it go sour you know
you you can't just blame yourself
completely it's a two-way street but you
can look at that relationship and be
like you know what
i stopped doing this i stopped looking
after me i stopped you know because like
i was in a relationship a long time ago
and i remember that
um one of the things that that i
realized
was that i wasn't doing the stuff i
needed to do
for me like i wasn't pursuing my career
i wasn't taking care of my health i got
so fat like fatter than i even was when
you guys saw me
which in recent years you know and and
then you look back and you go well i
would have broken up with me too
so and i told myself after that i would
never not
look after myself i would never not like
pursue my career and like make sure that
you know
i make sure that i'm i'm right there
it's like 1a1b in terms of like
especially if you get into a great
relationship you know
you've got to make sure that you're
taking care of yourself too and doing
your part so look back on those
relationships and be like what was i not
doing
how did it fail because you're blaming
yourself and you shouldn't
it's not your fault it's not all your
fault
you know it's not and you can look back
and be like well you know what i wasn't
doing this i wasn't doing that
and do those things now you know do
those things now
and you'll be fine you know but don't
take
like all this burden on yourself like as
if you did
you know like you're the criminal in all
this situation you're not
so start looking after you start working
out do all those things that make you
feel good because when you feel good
people around you're going to be like
that guy feels good then you're going to
have confidence in yourself and when you
have confidence
that's attractive okay so
get that mojo back
all right guys that was real world
advice from a grown ass man
this is my relationship update and i
thought to myself
what better way for 100 episode
to have my relationship update with the
person that i'm in a relationship with
so welcome to the podcast for the first
time you've heard a lot about her
if you listen to my gaming channel you
already know about her because there's
emotes about her
all my gaming fans already know about
rachel but here she is
in the flesh in the riffin with griffin
studio
live for episode 100 my girlfriend
uh my fiancee rachel
thank you that was a great intro
[Laughter]
i really appreciated that wow
it's an honor to be your 100th episode
did you stop acting weird
stop acting weird she's in like you're
like in
presentation mode right now well this is
so hot
the third try i'm just trying to make
the best of it
oh my god yeah this is
i think that uh
quarantine has been coveted
quarantined everything i mean i think
people are in
two stages of their relationship they're
either in
i need to get out of this damn thing
what am i doing i can't live with this
person for the rest of my life
or they realize wow i work through all
this stuff and i
this is the one for me but i hate you or
i love you stage
yes i hate you are i love you um
what are you in right now
you hate me and i love you no
i do i hate you she's just driving me
crazy you just drive me crazy sometimes
you know that
you drive me crazy with your just but it
is what it is
we just work differently is what we're
realizing
it's it's it's part of what i love about
you though i guess you know what i mean
it's like there you go thank you i'm
just trying to sit up with my posture
yeah because she saw herself on the
camera and was like i'm slouching
my shirt is wrinkled you know she's such
a prissy
you said you're such a princess about
these kinds of things but i get it it is
what it is i i thought i looked a little
fat on that last take
gonna sit up taller be clearer
yeah so here we are uh we're doing good
you know
i think i don't know how everybody
else's relationship is out there but
this has definitely
accelerated uh our relationship i don't
know
well week one my mom kicked me out of my
house
and we're now living together yeah it
was like
we're closer than ever now right i think
so it was it was difficult at first
because you know you you
listen when you're in a relationship you
realize that
you make time to spend with someone
and then you're doing that spend time
stuff you
uh and then you have time then you know
oh i'm going away she's going away he's
going away i'm going back to my own
place
and then you're like whoo you can just
breathe and decompress
but when you like live with somebody
there's no time for that you're just
always around each other
so you just have to learn to you learn
like a
language a dance which we've been
getting to know in the kitchen yes
because
the kitchen at first the kitchen was a
nightmare because she likes to do things
completely different than i like to do
you know
like like just let me tell you how
rachel wants
just how that's how rachel cooks
so that we she comes in the kitchen she
turns the stove on
puts the pot on the stove and then goes
what are we making
that's first step preheating the oven
preheating the skillet it's not a
skillet it's a
nonstick expensive you literally just
went i said
i said make something and you put the
pot on turn and i say what are you going
you can't
you can't just you can't just start the
stove without it
there's no prep there's no prep with her
so this was a problem at first
and she didn't like my attitude because
i'm whatever about my
my bossy demeanor in the kitchen so that
was bothering her
and then her like blase attitude about
where things go and how we do
things was bothering me but then cut to
like seven months later
we're in the kitchen just zipping around
each other you know spinning them back
and giving each other bumping butts yeah
and not even minding and not minding i
think that that is
i think that we've found a way to work
through all the all the bad stuff
and you know i wouldn't change it for a
million years
thank you i would change a few things
about you but
we're working on it wow team
we're working on it it's a community
effort
wow so so oh so we trying to be 100 on
here that's what you're trying to
because i could could go down my list of
things
this woman man i swear to god okay so
we are like i said if you heard earlier
i said fiance
engaged it is a weird process it's weird
to be engaged
in um kovit you know my buddy moe mandel
got married
we were invited but it was up in oregon
you know and i guess i said to you i was
like me
we obviously didn't go we're not going
to work sorry you know what i mean
even though i love weddings yeah but
it's just one of these things so we
actually were invited to
like three weddings my other but i don't
even know if they even did their wedding
it was gonna be up in this like farm up
in like montecito or whatever it was
so it's like it's weird times but so for
me it's like i
rachel doesn't like surprises okay i
know this about her
she's i just look he she does not like
support right
right you don't like surprises correct
so
when i was like when we knew
it was time it was like okay let's get i
want to get married i
knew she's the one i knew i couldn't
just go out and get a ring
right right i
wanted to do my research i wanted to
look i love to shop
so yeah she does
i didn't want anything to be taken from
me right
so we were in the process of that she
even made an appointment at the
different ring
places we're gonna go in and look
together because she wanted me to go
with her i didn't want to go
i had my own reasons because i i wanted
i wanted
her to figure out what she wanted and
then i go on my own
so it could be a little bit of surprise
so i feel like you know that's
what i wanted but she didn't want that i
mean i understand that
but i just always in the back of my mind
remember my mom like
maybe five years ago she was like
it was like one of their big and gay or
um
one of their anniversaries anniversaries
and she finally
had the courage to speak up and say
can i get a new ring i've i've never
really liked this
one oh wow and obviously my dad was like
of course get whatever you want you know
we've been married this long so like she
finally got the ring
that she wanted but um from that
i took with me like
might as well speak up in the beginning
i get that
so we were okay so and i took all that
on i was like okay great if that's how
you want to do it
because you don't know like what you're
supposed to do in these situations you
just go based off movies
you know what i mean right and i never
really looked at rings
and when i walked in the store they're
like what cut do you want i'm like
what cut do you have yeah so then it
turned into like a whole thing for her
so cut to i want to do it we're
scheduled an appointment
covey hits we're in quarantine we even
had an appointment during
covid remember oh yeah we even went to
work with it but it was like
they didn't even they didn't even want
to see us they didn't want to see us so
you know so cut two we're now locked
away my business
shuts down you know there's no comedy
there's no acting there's no nothing so
i'm sitting here thinking to myself too
like
when am i gonna make money again like
you know i have savings i'm a frugal guy
so i got all my money in the bank you
know what i mean i like to i've always
thought
because when you're in the entertainment
business every job i get when the job's
done i think i'm never gonna work again
yeah and even my hours got cut so i was
very understanding as well the whole
world changed yeah the world changed so
it turned her credit to you was very
understanding about like i can't get you
this like big old diamond yeah
i mean even my best friends were
getting married and they had a you know
they had to downsize yeah
so i totally i get it
okay so cut to then i went on a zoom
call with her family because we do this
her family does this great zoom meeting
which was
my idea to continue it it started on uh
was it passover yeah passover
they have the dinner of seder right you
have the jews have this
the cheese love to celebrate [ __ ] okay
by the way and the first two nights are
very important so we did
each side of the family had a night
because i have a large family
yeah she has a big family on either both
sides of her family but it was hilarious
your grandma trying to make the zoom
work on her ipad so that was like
i talked about it on my podcast by the
way because it was so funny just her
like i don't see
it you know and then it's just her face
on the screen and she's like
looking for the button so that was fun
so then she really enjoyed it
um because she's in florida where in
florida
my um
what city i'm saying we're not we're not
going to give her address
oh yeah so she's in like a nice part of
florida but she's in this retirement
place it's like an independent living
but they're very strict about the
quarantine because she's in a
a risky age range you know she's in that
age range where
if covet hits it could decimate that
whole place so they're really worried
about that and they wanted to be safe
so we zoom in she's by herself it gets
lonely
it's depressing so here's the family
coming in with like hey here we are
and then first go ahead yeah so after
passover
we decided to come up with topics every
week
to like make a video about something to
like present to my grandma so it's not
so it doesn't take a long
time it's already like put together and
it's kind of
like a show-and-tell from each side of
the family like everyone and her family
really gets into it like they all like
they all like they put together these
really elaborate videos
her uncle aaron like he thinks he's a
history teacher
so this this dude like he'll
he'll be like uh here's here's uh
something from in 1980
in 1855 and then blah blah blah he like
goes into that
her aunt is a psychologist so she likes
to like dig
in deep and like get in everybody's
business you know what i mean love her
you know what i mean she's just and then
and then all her cousins and they they
want to be actresses and they're fun
they're doing their tick tocks and
they're doing all this stuff and we're
presenting all this to bubby
booby how you say it bubby bubby bubby
it's very jewish yeah she's so jewish
she's great though and she's a sharp
woman bright
that's one thing i i really especially
because in my situation because my mom
is like got dementia and so it's
difficult to like
so when i see a woman who's like older
than my mom and she's still shy
your grandma's sharp you know she she's
like she's like a detective she'll ask
like
that's why it's tough to be on the zoom
if you're like new
like because they are tough on you like
like her cousin jake
brought his girlfriend on the zoom and
everybody was like
so where are you from what are you
studying tell us about yourself
you know so it's very nosy yeah yeah
they're nosy
you love the drama nosy dramatic family
but they're great
um so we did the zoom and then i
suggested after the passover i said
you actually do it every week it seems
like your grandmother really loves it
rachel passed on that message and then
now they're doing it and we've been
doing it for months now
you know and i think it's and i think
it's a great way to stay in contact with
your family that's something you would
not have done before
like covet has made us find different
ways to connect and i think it's
great right what do you think about what
do you think about the zoom
um i love it um i don't always get to be
on the zoom calls because of work
but honestly now i almost want to take
off sundays just to
have this one day of like family day
yeah
it is a it is a nice thing and i do
suggest i do suggest you all do that so
that's that's
you know what's been going on and then
instead of like getting rachel ring
right now because
her car was a mess was breaking down
the ac didn't work the radio didn't work
the blinker didn't work
the lock didn't work the lock didn't
work everything so i got rachel a
promise car
you know believe me it's not a mercedes
it's a car she wanted actually she
because rachel's a research person
she was looking at youtube videos and
comparing all the models and
i had a certain price range so we got
her
a promised car
you like it right yes with a 360 camera
favorite feature i don't know what i was
doing without one rachel didn't have a
reverse cam
like an animal in her last car like uh
like like we living in the stone age
you have to turn your neck to reverse
her last car like it was i hated driving
that car
but this is something that i'm glad you
brought this up because this is
something that
so now rachel got the camera she cannot
park
the car not at all without turning the
front camera on now
you know people behind me get upset
because i
get upset i need to turn the camera on
before turning it's so she's in her
element
and i know people get a little bit like
weirded at like weirded out because
something we should talk about because i
don't know if you know i don't know i
told you but i didn't really go into
detail on it but
so rachel's tall you're like how tall
are you i'm like
a good you're six you're she's six foot
she's got a six in a number so
that's tall for uh for a woman you know
so she's tall she's slender
and she has trouble getting jeans so on
my str i'm on my game stream eric
griffin gaming which i do
every day um and oh yeah they can get
some merch rachel has some merch on
right now eric griffin gaming merch
very quality it's good stuff and she's
actually gonna be in charge of it to
change some of designs and stuff like
that but anyways
she has trouble buying jeans
you know there's literally one website
i've gone on from the age of like
13 to now of like where i would buy my
jeans
yeah and because but recently they
started
not running out of my size right because
it's not that
it's also not that she just talks she's
also all legs you know rachel's like her
torso is like this big then it's like
head and then it's like legs
you got a lot she got long legs your
inseam is like something ridiculous 37
inches yeah she got a 37 inseam okay so
she can't find jeans so and rachel's
fancy
you fancy i mean i'm not fancy enough to
have a tailor
or custom-made jeans wow you see where
her brain went okay
right but so she's on some website i
mean
the website i usually buy it's usually
like
29 for a pair of jeans so i'm not used
to spending a lot of money
but then i found these jeans at
neiman marcus and they fixed the brand
perfectly
they're selene celine is the brand okay
they fit her but they're how much
eight hundred dollars they're eight
hundred dollars you heard me correct
eight hundred dollars so let me just you
i'm gonna get back to you
okay so she's telling me that she comes
in my room she's like i found some jeans
or 800
and i go are you crazy you're not gonna
spend 800
on jeans when i know i we could find
jeans
i go online cause i'm talking [ __ ] i'm
like i'll find you some jeans
what's your size i go online and sure
enough
you can't find this particular size no
they're hard to find
you you and every website you go you go
to jeans for tall women uh
look 37 inseam you go to all these sites
and i found the one
they're sold out you can't even
pre-order so
i go i guess these are the only jeans
and then she's like see
i told you i felt bad the gaming has
been going
well i've been making some money with
that and i go you know what i'm gonna
buy you the jeans
so these are the jeans yeah so i'm
wearing the jeans okay but
online on social media there's this big
thing going around this big article
about how celine jeans didn't
fit the like um the
fit model for like a photo shoot oh oh
wow
so like they say you hate me
well you know actually i did freak out a
little bit when i went in the store
and i wasn't the size that i thought i
was either
but i mean i started birth control this
year so i did gain a little weight
so i had to go up on size so like i just
thought
weight you'd be like what two pounds i
mean
i just thought i had to go up the size i
didn't think anything of it
other than i gained some weight
but it wasn't a big deal to me because
like you mean size you mean like the
waist
size or like the what what size you'd go
up a jean size oh like it's not that big
of a
deal but like if you're like in a photo
shoot and
they're buying like or they're like
borrowing like sample sizes and you
don't fit into
the clothes then they don't have any
images to use
from the photo shoot because they're
like you don't fit in the clothes and
then
it makes the model feel bad because they
didn't fit and they kind of blame it on
the model
and what they're doing is like kind of
blaming it
on celine because they're not making
these
jeans that actually fit humans kind of
only like these virtual oh right
women who obviously don't take birth
control
what but i mean that has nothing to do
with it but
oh who fluctuate in size is really what
you're trying to say so
okay so then but these genes still fit
you fine
i mean i don't mind going up the size no
no no but the point is the g
they fit me perfect thank you celine all
right so
i will be back okay well with your own
money
um you know so then i got
you know i got into a little thing like
somebody was sending me a message like
in these tough times oh yeah the fact
that you're spending that kind of money
on that and listen guys look
even my dad listened to your podcast
about that
and got on my case and goes rachel do
you need these jeans
i don't know eric's fans don't like them
it is what it is you know what i'm not
gonna but let me finish i'm not gonna
apologize
for doing okay the gaming has been doing
well for me
and i've gotten a lot of great
opportunities i've worked hard in my
career
if i want to spend 800 on my chick
that's my business
yes i'm putting it out here and it's if
you want to feel the way you want to
feel about it that's fine but i don't
care
just to be honest with you like deal
with your own deal with your own [ __ ]
you know if you have a you have you know
that's that's your thing
i can't save the world i do what i can
to give entertainment to people
and people send me messages on the daily
saying like
hey thanks for the content i really need
it so hey
i i took a moment it makes my girl happy
i bought her the damn jeans and here
they are yeah and i appreciate it and
i've never been able to walk into a
store and buy jeans that actually
fit like floor length jeans and i
love them i i that experience alone
well there you go see so that's just uh
that that's that's the update that's
what's been happening with us
um you know like i say things are good
right
i think things are good um things are
great yeah things oh yeah
i like that that's a good way to say it
things are great you know
i don't know how everybody else is doing
out there during during
you know these strange times if you're
in a relationship and you're feeling
weird about it i mean
i mean i've definitely cried every day
you've cried every day are you crying
rachel will cry okay i wish i could
remember the stupid movie we were
watching
this before covet we're sitting in the
theater it's the dumb movie
we're saying to each other wow this
movie's terrible
but then cut to there was like a brief
touching moment at the end of the movie
i look over
she's bawling like she
[Laughter]
she will cry at anything at any time
just like if there's like anything
touching on the screen even i
like oh by the way i forgot to mention
this so like you know when we
in the proposal it's like so like rachel
has this thing i had this thing i like
well let me pre-propose practice
so then i get anything like for instance
if i i would get this
because it has like a thing on it and i
would be like
baby level my life
will you be my bride and then i would do
like
it would be like my practice proposal
[Laughter]
and then i love it and then she starts
crying every time we cry
hey we well i cried a couple times too
because you really get
i really feel like it's touching it it
is this is how it feels yeah
it's just as good as any ring well
yeah but you still want a ring i still
wanna woman's obsessed well
i mean when you are like born
thinking like one day you're gonna get
married and have a wedding ring
like i don't know you just
hey you have to apologize yeah i get i
get it
all of my relatives are happily married
and it's just like
are they happily married
[Laughter]
well this will be another episode
like we'll delve into it
yeah we'll delve into rachel's family's
uh uh
you know weird relationships later but
listen babe
um thank you for having me i love you so
much
yeah i love you too thank you griffin
fans
griffin gaming riffing with griffin
riffing with griffin
wait hold on a second
oh no i don't know if i have to
oh
well i don't know if i have it on guys
maybe can we do it together
maybe i should take the time to uh
finish it off you know what i'm gonna
get it right now i'm gonna do one of
those rick glassman cuts guys
ready hold on yes
so we did it and so rachel wants to hit
the woo-woos
and so ladies and gentlemen uh you know
from the great detective design
is and uh dopapod
the great band the great jazz funk band
made this song for me so as you know for
episode 100
[Music]
your favorite podcast
episode 100 and you guys you know the
name
that's what i do rage
so ladies and gentlemen uh i always hand
the singing mic over to the guest
so what you got
[Music]
[Music]
i got all your shirts and i wear them
every day
[Music]
all right ladies and gentlemen thanks a
lot for watching this is episode 100
this is my beautiful lady rachel we did
it uh 100 episodes i'm looking for 100
more so please
please keep subscribing listening
sharing
and doing all that great stuff and you
can also catch me on erica from gaming
every single day
on twitch and i always put the videos up
on youtube also so
and thank you for watching and i will
see you next week thank you guys
thank you
[Music]
you